when you tube ouais je suis en train de
me laver attend on chantonne me laver
les dents je devais à béatrice de
trappes est en train de me laver les
dents jam
alors
voilà
[Musique]
enfin
ouais si vous deviez qui régit ne pense
pas non
j'ai en moi
les panthères
pas
bonsoir ah non mais alors
mon
non mais
oh
[Musique]
c
non
[Musique]
m
oh
et
dubaï
non
[Musique]
c
non
c'était comment cet oiseau ces jeunes
garçons les aboiements et toi on fait
des photos etc et wiiware d'aller demain
on l'a rencontré en 90 comme modèle et
petit à petit on a travaillé ensemble
quand je suis l'assistance alice et
laurent l'a rencontré deux ans
[Musique]
dans l'eau
vous
[Musique]
m
pour les garçons
c'est bizarre non
oh
m
il
mais
[Musique]
le mur il a pendant longtemps j'étais
derrière fait bizarre comment s'est
passée la cavalerie qui s'arrache him
away et portier avec les électriciens
qui étaient venus rendre qu'à lui seul
il a sauté par dessus
enfin quand il y est c'est fait attendre
que les choses se passent
belle promenade moi je n'ai pas entendu
un seul sait combien alors deux en deux
ans c'est vrai ça fait huit saisons ça
fait 8 6 ans ça fait tout de plus de 700
jours 700 nuit sont les plus longues
c'est la nuit ou
qu'est ce qui faisait le soir le soir
entre le marché du siècle et les infos
des petites séries de pompes
ouais de centre simple série d'abdos
alors ils n'étaient pas laisser aller à
je bouquine est un petit peu il faut le
tout c'était de l'oubli un petit peu
l'endroit où on n'était pas ce que c'est
vraiment l'endroit
je crois que plus bas y'a pas quoi après
après ça il ya peut-être la maladie est
certainement là tu vois des gens que
j'aime
une cigarette pourrait stopper
c'est surtout un formidable levier sur
la douleur
c'est l'impression que tu parles pour un
voyage tu connais pas la destination à
tout le monde souffre
ça faisait quelque chose comme un putois
on se fait partie de penser quoi
ce qui me fait le plus fier c'est
d'avoir un fils et deux ans de ma vie
pour rien quand même devant on va voir
si tout le monde va tenir sa parole il
faut que tu as payé ce qui est appelé
pour y relancer des gens de ton regard
de la même manière problème il est là qu
est ce qu on te fait croire des trucs
que notre petit ça se regarde les
regards vers la cellule la ola
ils regardent tf1
la vie regardent tf1 parce que il ya un
peu de sexe de bouder les maquis sont
topless outre comme ça ouais mais c'est
dur parce que des combats une nana à la
télé on
si mal c'était tout est absent depuis
aucune forme de prison là la moindre
moments de tendresse de sexe et tous et
à bannir fort niveau me regarder les
infos on regarde et on regarde la marche
du siècle comme ça c'est ce qui manque
le plus c'est les grossesses
bizarrement pas tellement car ce qui
manque le plus c'est la tendresse et
d'amour
le cul le cul pour te dire la vérité
depuis que je suis sorti depuis deux ans
il n'a rien eu quoi
ouais pas c'est finalement c'est un
muscle c'est vrai que plus que tout une
traîne plus ça marche
quoi ce qui manque surtout c'est la
tendresse en fait tendresse et l'amour
lugos montrent beaucoup râlé petites
cellules allumé la voie à ça fait six
mètres carrés ça en plus la santé ce
tube de prison donc les becs tu vois il
se passe des trucs de fenêtre en fenêtre
avec un yoyo
c'est un truc c'est une corde qui est
attaché avec un poids et si par exemple
cap une cigarette tout ap
il aimait qui mettons bright envoie la
corde tu l'envoies la cellule d'à côté
c'est l'heure où ils sont fermées la
salle de la rode s'énervant ya de
l'entraidé entre les mains un peu
voyez je suis d'avis que entre entre
race est entre gens dire les gens qui
sont là par accident ou les gens quand
il ya deux classes khwaja ce don pour
qui c'est normal d'être là et ceux pour
qui c'est avec six antennes voilà il ya
des mecs c'est inscrit dans leur
parcours quoi tu les entends l'a pas si
longtemps il s'appelle de cellule à
cellule il parle pas à quelqu'un qui est
dehors
puisqu'il a solana qui est en face
la viennale accaparent les tue le voilà
seul à 0,1
donc c'est ce à quoi il ya ceux qui sont
là par accident et ceux qui sont là
parce que c'est le pakistan
en puisant que des histoires de plus
dans trois comtés
quand la santé dans le 82 tel endroit
simon doit régler tout cela ce sont en
général des mecs qui sont les moins
chiant bien à toi la ligne juste devant
la gauche
les mecs qui l'aimaient kelly scott un
peu le parloir
parce que en fait le par lens a dit
aussi surveiller est intéressante à
surveiller la ronde a dû passer du vin
anti fini peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent
de dire ce qu'ils veulent c'est un peu
un petit contact avec le monde extérieur
c'était véritablement nous parle elle
ici tu fais tout sur place enfin tu le
dois enfin le sexe qu'est ce tu fais ni
drôle que ça donne pas envie de te faire
un mec de temps en temps ça arrive ça
mais ça m'a paru le sait ce que c'est
une goutte une fois par curiosité puis
après ça devient un plaisir tout prix si
cette fois voulu mettre les doigts dans
le village vient d il ya des choses qui
se passent qui évidemment se passait
plus en vue ce qui est grave c'est que
ça se passe sans préservatif
il faut pas se sont assurés quoi il ya
quand même des choses qui se passent en
prison qui sont très graves dans le
manque d'assistance médicale la manière
de ce qu'il faut payer pour être en
prison ça coûte minimum de 1000 balles
par mois à partir pour vivre pour
bouffer un acteur si t'as pas les 2000
d'un métier mort tu vous fait la belle
jean paul ii paire de baskets il faut
faire gaffe c'est quoi est ce qui était
arrivé de pierres ce qui m'est arrivé de
pire ouais je crois que tous les jours
c'est l'humiliation cancer commandé par
des mecs tu calcules même pas candidat
alcoolémie ce qui m'est arrivé de pirlo
j'ai vraiment eu très peur c'est quand
des mecs mais c'est une mort à côté
ouais je sais comment ils font un robe
site un poste dans la cellule que tu as
acheté de coin jarry douche 1
c'est la fourchette ou on le couteau
tailler un déguisé fourchette ou est-ce
que les églises contre sous les trucs du
lavabo
est ce que le lavabo en général moi
j'étais dans une prison qui tient de
plus moderne que la santé sont en
porcelaine donc que l'intérieur c'est
comme comme dugré mais assez dur tu as
quand même fier un couteau dont qu'ils
aiguisent là dessus et je me suis fait
coincer aux douches un bon rouge avec
une solution c'était de défendre
vanek a glissé voilà quand j'ai pris un
coup de fourchette dans le dos on est
secoué par terre ça m'a valu deux mois
de plus et ta femme est allée droit de
venir te voir tous les dimanches avec
les gosses ah ouais ça aussi ce que me
rend difficile parce que tu sais pas
trop ce que tu me racontes ton gosse est
vrai que les gamins ils nous regardent
la télé quand tu regardes un feuilleton
américain pas les méchants mais sur leur
prison ouais qu'est ce tu dis à ton
quand même qu'à 4 1 tu dis quoi quand il
anime la prison se fait pour les gens
méchante papa et des méchants c'est
vachement dur à gérer tout ça
c'est un véritable exercice c'est une
remise en question complète il faut moi
j'ai tenu le coup parce que parce que
j'avais des gens qui les mecquois des
gens comme toi comme la croix comme deux
amis du désert aisée et pbd maubert bon
ben voilà c'est grâce à sa balance l'est
faut balancer la liste des complices
c'est pas des complices parce que je me
connaissent mais on était bien
malheureux en tous les cas pour toi moi
j'étais pas s'être rendu plus fort oui
j'ai beaucoup plus appris de terminer je
suis beaucoup plus lucide je sais ce que
je veux ouais je sais où je veux arriver
je t'ai vu dans flash back couette une
prière que quand tu es parti tu n'iras
avec les caméras de surveillance toute
la journée en même temps de m
ouais mais tu sais je crois que c'est
bien c'est une belle épreuve
mais si tu sors si tu sors plus fort de
la secte efforts en tête les sorties
entier à ça
moi j'ai beaucoup fait de sport et puis
je crois que le talentueux perd pas la
fois que tu y as moment j'ai douté
vraiment que j'ai douté de tout du monde
de ce que mes parents m'avaient appris
parce que c'était sont des anciens
enseignants
j'ai douté de pas de mes amis parce que
toi tu as été le premier à faire un
premier signe et j'ai douté j'ai douté
des flics j'en doute toujours tu n'iras
pas ce que parce que des choses que je
pourrais jamais digéré quoi mais tu sais
les mecs souffre dedans on se rendra
compte 150 ce qu'ils vivent
parce que si le mec équitablement il a
fait un truc c'est normal il accepte
mais il ya des choses qui se passent qui
sont pas normales les politiques
commencent à en parler maintenant parce
qu'ils y vont parce qu'ils y vont il
faudrait qu'ils viennent un peu plus
souvent dans les prétoires il faudrait
que malheureusement tu sais je crois que
reconnaître ses erreurs toi tu disais
que toutes les vérités bonnes à dire
ouais mais tout le monde pense pas ce à
quoi alors on se cache mesure l'on ferme
les mecs c'est vrai qu'il faut les
enfermer parce qu'ils leur donnent du
style son faux vrai quoi on pourrait pas
vivre avec des pierres à l'intérieur
c'est très grave les gens qui sont là
des gens qui ont fait des trucs
j'allais dire pas pardonnable des
méchants méchants faire gaffe tu peux
pas qu'est ce qu'il y en a dont tu
penses que c'est bien qu'ils soient
maintenant quand même ce que tu es
rencontres tout à fait ainsi mieux que
ce soit dedans
bien sûr sinon pour nos gosses une femme
se serait pas mis la main dans la main
pour nous ça va bien à côté de ça c'est
pas fait pour des gens comme nous quoi
moi je préférais partir à sarajevo à
partir au rwanda j'aurais préféré un
service colati commenterez d'utilité
publique sur qui tape avant d'enfin qui
serait dit obligé à mettre des disques
dans les hospices
ouais pour faire danser les
paraplégiques ou non en fait voilà
j'aurais fais avec plaisir
ouais mais là tu perds ton temps quand
apprend à devenir plus con que la
moyenne est à ce point de battre tu
apprends à te tiens par mentir ça
reprend
ah merde tu veux un gamin ici à 18 ans
il sort ses mômes atomique quoi laisser
voler les voitures il sait tout faire
mais put ainsi que ça fait vraiment
bizarre
malade et c'est de danser tout petit
laid mais qu'il marche tu marches toute
la journée en fait ouais il ya un
endroit qui s'appelle la promenade où tu
sors une heure par jour
mais les envois qui sont réservées aux
canines
dans ce sens il emmagasine d'autres qui
se sont réservé yves j'allais dire menu
frotin la loi qui était considéré comme
en moi j'avais le droit de marcher les
quelques yi ouais parce que je passe à
la télé tout ça pour dire mais donc tu
me rassures précis on a fait un petit
peu de télé on est mieux traité ça fasse
beaucoup du côté du détenu en tout cas
quoi saint pacôme quartier ici la
dernière fois que tu viens c'est
certainement la dernière fois que je
viens c'est quoi ces civils et lyrique
sallabi nous c'est amusant
qu est ce qu avait dedans avant ouais ça
c'est la lumière
à cete de la guerre ce qui situe la
bière juge a acheté avant c'est fini la
viola pour l'instant oui j'en fais le
voeu de voir quoi après après la bière
aza dia
là où vous habitez au du bois jeux la
roue qu avant oui ça pour toi et vous
venez d'où qui mois à la route que la
route de la radio depuis combien de
temps le mois et là mais l'urgence avant
toujours la route
nous allons essayer pourquoi le mélange
prend le chemin ouais le jeu maintenant
là je trouvais cela riches pour un
schéma
ouais ça va bien ça ça au revoir oui ça
va bien tu vois où je choisir mon regard
m
où
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
et bonsoir bienvenue retiendra un an
avant
voilà ce qu'ils gardent meilleurs au
monde
we can
papa
ces luminaires blanc unis
à
chacun sait nos envies de chacun quand
on possède un bon comme
oui attendons comme le
par balles ou pendus changé
j'ai toujours mais je vais bien je ne
sais quoi
je marchais dans la nuit je cherche à
l'oublier mais c'est plus fort que moi
jamais des yeux je les passe droits
ça ne l'est jamais
nous d'être à ma cm de traiter tous les
jours
l'histoire d'amour
le
non
jal est tellement dans la peau par
contre j'en suis là retour d'un climat
proche c'est fini je suis à lui
ça
à
je ne sais pas
y en a marre
tous nos lagons john a
à
écoutez le tube en délaissant un bon
test
il y a
je penses quoi toi tout aussi bien
tu n'aimes pas c'est un âge que je
t'aime que je t'aime que j plein
jeunes
m
le plat
mais tant pis
à voir
alors
merci
ça va bon ben oui non c'est pas la balle
même faire don grands fous rires on dit
11h30 il est minuit moins 10 bah non non
non non pas fumé quoi hein
alors je fais quoi moi je suis une bonne
et je fais une poubelle sur cheval
attendent toute l'année mais là on en a
rien à [__] ou pas reste scotché à la
télévision et ben alors là il peut se il
peut se les gelait toute la nuit
11h30 je me suis sans heurts et brice
est un mini moins 10 morts en même temps
comme créatrice et non seulement ces
soirées en plus les jours vous dire moi
c'est moi moi je travaille je fais un
boulot je sois du qatar a mis les moyens
personne n'avait survécu à sa chute
waters poser mes concerts se dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est moi non plus encore
il est passé coutu tous voulaient faire
combien de temps avec ton émission je
sais perdre leur pourrit minutes
tournent de plus en poche doha chez moi
à leurs besoins n'a rien quoi qu'est ce
que tu fais chier je suis assez bon
s'est étendu sous caisse le maoût de
tout le monde sait bien c'est bien voilà
on est heureux on est on se rend compte
son élément alors alors alors quand même
pas dur de respecter un horaire merde ça
s'est bien passé ce soir son spectacle
mais non je ne pars pas dans des
questions gentillesse et j'arrive pas à
jamais oui et ça s'est bien passé la
soirée était belle jusqu'à ce que tu
jusqu'à ce que tu me faut de 20 minutes
dans le sang était content
les gens étaient contents les gens au
moins il était à l'heure il est encore
loin on leur dit 20h34 très bas ils
n'arrivent pas à 23 heures à 23 heures
c'est fini oui j'étais comme ça allait
oui ça allait bien mais c'est pas ton
petit ton mielleux toute façon être
achetés avec un peu oui
ah bah oui gilles benoist et si une idée
oui et si on allait au théâtre grévin
écoute je sais pas si tu le mérites
cinq minutes alors et avril après gendre
un mois on y va tout de suite alors tu
traînes pas que je me mets pas tout une
équipe bis pour passe pas chez toi on
est d'accord maintenant ça y va
maintenant pendant l agent met d'accord
en mars ailleurs alors à longvic tu
connais le chemin
ouais
allez
voilà mais avec des trucs qui tout près
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces gens s'attroupent facilement les
c'est ça qui me gêne c'est qu'on prend
c'est que moi je je je
j'aurais voulu qu'on règle de ce conte
entre toi et moi sinon t'as vu comment
tu sais tu fous la merde tu vois je
n'aime pas ça quand les gens nous
regardent seulement toi tu es un corrigé
à la ce soir là
résumons d'état famine et bien sûr j'ai
déjà allé au musée également pas
vraiment nous regardes tu espères y
rentrer un jour eh ben c'est pas en
arrivant avec 20 minutes de retard quand
tu seras ça tu fais là dedans voilà ici
mes tracts en anglais c'est qui jean
impassible on l'appelle l'impassible
gens vrais gens impassible gens à sa
feria
j'espère que tout ça t'inspire un peu
tard que tout cet asile un peu plus de
bar aba j'espère oui quand même voilà je
suis quand même un peu navré de
constater que je t'emmène voir des
personnages historiques puis toi t'es
qu'une hâte c'est de courir retourner
voir claudia schiffer quoi c'est là que
tu pourras jamais te décrotter de ça et
en plus ce qui est pénible je m'excuse
de te le dire ce qui est pénible c'est
que quand je t'en fais le reproche aux
lieux humblement au mieux tranquillement
1 2 me dire ben oui j'ai un peu exagéré
je suis un peu idiot je suis un peu
léger je suis un peu frivole et ben non
talent est à l'air content de toi en
plus un dd voilà je te montre voltaire
je te montre pascal oui mais maintenant
tu regarde par terre mais c'est pour
faire ton cinéma c'est pour faire ton
cirque en fait y'a pas de rédemption
possible tu seras toujours attiré par
les boîtes de nuit les boîte à partouze
la la drogue et les verres de whisky
coca 1
j'essaye de te montrer dans des endroits
où que ce passage et c'est mettez ça et
rien on te montre molières théâtre était
en train de ricaner de chercher du
haschich dans ta poche jeu dont on
montre pascal tu étais en train de
penser aux fesses de claudia schiffer
que tu ne pourra même pas touché en plus
alors on comprend non seulement de nom
non seulement tu es des voiliers mais en
plus tu es mégalomane tu n'auras pas
tout ça tu ferais mieux de rentrer chez
toi de lire
beau livre tu feras mais d'aller
regarder une bonne pièce de théâtre à
moudre à étudier un petit peu
shakespeare de te mettre un petit peu de
plomb dans la tête banon toi il faut que
tu sois là mais un machin dire ah bah
oui ça y est je crois que j'en ai fait
le tour et les le voile est il
recommença à retourner voir les espèces
de drag kings queens kling 1 dans les
dents dans des boîtes à 300 mille balles
le le whisky voilà alors tu vas te
plaindre après qu'est ce que tu veux que
je te dise et encore je me retiens si
c'est pour aller de coucher oui mais non
non si c'est pour retourner
qu'est ce que tu vas faire mas d'azil
eux qu'est ce que tu as fait du porno
amateur à l'aller launier et voilà et
voilà pourquoi ils pensaient à claudia
schiffer et bien alors les sujets
ardisson ils sont diversifiées il ya un
type qui fait du porno amateur
un type qui fait du porno professional
pilot menaces et 2 qui passe est très
différent un deuxième deux types qui
font du porno amateur et l'autre va
passer professionnel un binôme bas ils
annonceront sujet c'est des
professionnels du bateau qui décide de
passer à l'acte pourquoi j'ai envie
c'est simplement ça c'est varié ça va
leur plaire à la chaîne a un petit peu
de cul comme saab et après ben qu'est-ce
que vous avez 21 10 me sur l'érotisme
mais amateurs ou professionnels en
passant s'est passé ça le sujet
justement on enquête un petit peu on se
demande
voilà dans l'allée recettes
d'aujourd'hui tu veux venir
heureusement qu'il me reste tu veux
venir françois c'est ce que je veux
venir je moi je faisais tu commencé si
je viens je devais voir à quelle vitesse
je vais vous mettre tout ça en prison
marianne voilà voilà voilà ce qui est
bon pour moi je veux bien venir et puis
leur dit elle à la montrer la beauté
dans une petite fleur de colza pour
essayer qui retrouve là un sentiment une
espèce de toutes petites pureté si c'est
possible mais non ils font du porno
amateur parce que tu me dises à des gens
qui sortent du porno amateur il n'y a
rien et coûte au moins ici tu aura pris
un petit bain j'espère te dois de
rappeler derrière le voilà tu peux l'air
de quelque chose et titre
dans dix quinze ans battue de dire oui
il ya autre chose 1
c'est complet rabbits médiatement
j'habite moi immédiatement
à la base il ya six mois
des familles toi tu manges et demi
lovato sont en phase d'écouté
comment ça marche
catane - journée voir les filles
manquantes semaine qui la ville
oh
j'habite de seul avec maman
e
vieil appartement
[Musique]
bruce arasa
j'aime
tenir compagnie
bonsoir bonsoir une fille virgal avant
toi bien oui on voulait vous dire
bonsoir pour y arriver pourquoi encore
pour quel plaisir pour l'occasion de
l'anniversaire de 1000 choquant c 501 50
ans j'ai besoin d'inviter voilà c'est
s'entendent michaud le primat lequel
voilà choix à savoir comment ça va ça va
très bien avec
bruce arasa
mais
pour contenir compagne et
une tortue
qu'un ami
une charge
super super qui je leur ai parlé avec
mon livre de t'expliquer redit son coin
la voilà
à cherry et pouvoir dans le cas comment
trouver entre autres qu'il était
maintenant aller en piste en piste aux
étoiles
ans
et ça prend les bambins
[Musique]
grâce à cacharel
new age à da on se détache les filles
oui on est prête à mener en deux minutes
sur seuls indices ont ouvert vers y est
on se dépêche
moi je regarde on se dépêche de prime a
bel et bien lieu sur l'accouchement
il faut bien c'est beau l'esprit ce qui
m'a dit michaud lui le dit mais le
cheveu ya les niveaux qui m'a dit on
dirait pas décevant dire la barbe à papa
ah oui tout à fait mais par le temps la
peinture est parti c'est vrai rien sinon
c'est le frottement le frottement ce que
je suis et rick ware est bien jeune
couple est aussi dangereusement
pas folle la guêpe
comme quoi les familles de tous les
jouets tous super haut point
on se dépêche
[Musique]
on se presse un peu
hortensia
pas celle là
khelladi
oh il faut déjà dit je comprends ma
femme se méfie toi j'ai raison quand je
te vois réserve est bien je comprends
que ma femme se méfie toi
l'ancien sultanat où l'art olalalala
venu dans cette loge je ne mens pas
toute nue heureusement on se dépêche un
bout de dix minutes pour compter le
bazar
à l'en croire à leurs yeux
je suis un bon mot
en 2010
super prêt alors tu joues la gauche ce
soir un peu après je sors oui c'est moi
où tu vas après au banana banana
prennent pour les yeux bouffis dit ça je
te promets
angers
[Applaudissements]
le
et ça
avec ça
jean quelconque parle
on s'en donne à coeur
forcer sur le noir est supérieurement
bouche de drag queen s'épanouir à coude
c'est un beau stade et drag queen et
c'est que maintenant ils les drag king
oui ça c'est extraordinaire ça défie du
sablon mach 22 23 ans que je fais ça je
vois bien garçons en journée parce que
john qu'on n'était pas comme ça monsieur
à l'intimité c'est que mène trois ans tu
jeanne encore le car il un bon en avant
cela on se dépêche
mais jean le fait avec nous
les nazis
homo
tablez
[Musique]
ça c'est le chat
qu as tu commencé la musique de cadbury
d'accord tous les deux
pour éviter cela
les coudes ans
j'ai pu me faire payer entre anciens je
ne fais pas dire
c'est soit vraiment aller salon
les six
oh
on line coince dacoury et sadique j'ai
aussi n'ont pas manqué dimanche soir
c'est saint jacques à souligner à manger
une choucroute la masse d'or est un cas
puis surtout en famille d'accueil a
conseillé par s'adresse partir alors ne
les ait secondes
m
bibi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
sco
[Musique]
fait drôle de voir chanter c'est ici
mais c'est l'endroit c'est un bon
endroit pour savoir larosace de notre
dame c'est un bon endroit
ah oui magnifique surtout le soir c'est
vrai qu'à pas le look à chanter ça de
toi la casta diva
ouais mais tu le fait très bien j'adore
cette chanson c'est la classe qui l'a
chanté
c'est magnifique magnifique
comment tu vis tous quitté arrive là tu
vois ça comment tu viens de loin quand
même tout est joué bages et jardiniers
la ville de quoi de mulhouse et de
colmar colmar
ouais la préfecture de colmar ouais
quiberon du recul c'est vrai que c'est
émouvant et sereine d'un jour donc
mesdames d'un seul coup un producteur
s'est intéressée à toi disons c'est vrai
que en même temps qu'elle jardini tu
découpes et des cadavres d'animaux c'est
quoi ce fou et ça c'était aux services
vétérinaires
j'avais travaillé car après balle
j'étais parti de nouveau sur colmar où
il ya une licenciement comme comme
jardinier
voilà c'est ça moi en suisse alain pas
si bien mais comme il appartient tous
les étrangers qui c'est là que j'ai
demandée pour de nouveau travailler à
colmar et vont ils retrouver cette place
mais pourquoi on découpe les cadavres
des animaux sera quoi ainsi pour faire
des autopsies armée pour voir la pouvoir
s'il était malade ou ce qu'ils avaient
comme l'alhambra soit 300 morts voilà la
soirée sur les animaux et ses amis sur
les animaux ni moi ce n'est pas
dérangeant de faire ça vraiment pour
dire au début c'était
c'est vraiment dur mais à force de
savoir pourquoi ces faits c'est
intéressant très intéressant c'est bon
les bateaux mouches magnifique
ah ouais
dommage tes clés centre
[Musique]
k
m
basset
[Applaudissements]
alors ce que paolo calia n'est là s'il
vous plaît pour thierry absents allons
même jour déjà dix ans que par le gallia
il est là ah non pardon
oh
mais
oui
balla
ce soir
très beau et encore plus beau qu'avant
venu magnifique
le pedn et
ouais j'ai peut-être oui
les eaux
oh
[Musique]
il change sont des maniaques
bonjour et l'on peut trouver
soyez les bienvenus on trouve facilement
avant c'est devenu un endroit
internationalement connu un jeudi dans
cette veine là et pour la nuit en
marcourt ça va on est content d'arriver
à temps et si je vois un truc max
pourquoi les chinois ou les japonais ils
ont besoin de fabriquer ça ici je crois
nous avec capable de faire des choses
parce que ce sont des gens qui ont vu la
chose d'une manière totalement
industriel et il fabrique des poupées
gonflables comme il fabrique des petits
canards pour aller à la plage pour les
gamins avec les mêmes procédés les mêmes
matériaux etc
alors ça ça ne ressemble à rien c'est
horrible
manifestement horrible est bon mais non
pas que tu fais ça tu vois il ya
maintenant parce qu'une dizaine d'années
presque une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
mais pour elle des bouteilles d'eau
voilà alors c'est à un système
relativement simples qu'on a pris parce
que toutes les poupées sont gonflés way
ou moins pendant une nuit avant d'être
mis dans le commerce doit être certain
qu'ils aient 28 et c'est donc on a un
souci de la qualité alors là elles sont
sur l'envers donc il faut pas regarder
l'aspect de finition puisque la leçon
sur l'envers et la peau sera retourné
pour donner cette eau de latex très
brillant très lisse et très agréable au
toucher son dû annoncer des mecs là oui
mais c'est simplement couvrir ce sera
remis à l'endroit c'est pour vérifier
qu'elles disent avoir une queue et
surtout deux lacs ont dégonflé très fort
pour être certain que y ait aucune fuite
en fait ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'on n'a jamais vus au qu'à l'être
humain avoir une queue derrière une
queue devant comme ce à quoi nous nous
sommes moins que ce ne soient pas les
siennes
voilà c'est quand même des êtres
extraordinaires c'est un peu comme
jacques pradel quand il a quantifié
l'extra terrestre situé à st le plan
physique du jeu c'est extraordinaire
cette année voilà comment y alors là
haut il ya toute la chaîne de
fabrication de poupées à d'accord c'est
le moulage là haut
voilà alors là c'est entièrement à
ouidah donc tu te rends pas en fait tu
trembles le moule dans le fût de la
terre natale en latex tu ressors et
après tu d'école latex du moule c'est ça
c'est fait une par une
voilà tout a nagé comme pressé ça y est
j'ai tout compris
oui sont tendus des inactifs elle son
confrère all blacks la semaine c'est
magnifique tu veux dire sont des
bossales sont bien cambrai tout va aller
très très joli film à travailler qu'est
ce que c'est beau ah oui oui je vois
plus beau ça c'est un rêve c est la
danse et le latex qui sèche en fait
voilà alors mais tout le processus est
automatisé way est bon cette chaîne ne
représente à peu près huit mois de
travail près de 2 millions
d'investissements et ça c'est le bal de
la charge cet influent avec du latex
mais c'est encore tout et après tu
d'école le latex du mois là on est
d'accord d'accord c'est une beauté total
c'est une oeuvre d'art sans un marché
[Musique]
brisant la glace
nous sommes les mannequins
faisant quelques pas à l'intérieur de la
ville sont minimales
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu